go ahead I'll give you the microphone
but I'm gonna give the microphone to
Maria's a long time my boy he wants to
say something you know I do and because
it's been so you about to propose to me
I'm gonna die oh my god it felt like I
was about to propose right now you're
doing know what dude it was just it was
so emotional to hear you say everything
your boyfriend of 19 years wants to talk
to you Maria yeah go ahead because you
know listening everything you said there
you know it that were we in the green
women talking about you know what you've
been through but I've been through with
you and it's just heart you know that
guy well put tears to because I think
about what we both have been through as
a couple and when we wanted to to be
together
you know we couldn't write because
people didn't want us together and then
being her parents yeah and family and
then it was it was literally like the
last 17 or 18 years of us you know
fighting together and me defending her
as best I could
um and you know and obviously we got to
a better place and you got a better deal
just really why she left the other job I
mean I don't know what business man
wouldn't take a better deal it was a
much better deal and it was global and
all that but but you know reminds me
just how much I do love you and and
although I said that this isn't a
proposal I want to ask you something
real you make me the happiest man on
earth and would you marry me I have to
go down a knee and get off the bike I'm
sorry I'd get down on your knee
get that mic near you I don't want to
miss the movie look at write quickly put
on some headphones goddammit headphone
oh yeah headphones on - get him on -
come on with you oh my god hey JT around
my [ __ ] money is this a joke what
with a big what did you say it's not a
joke come on this I wouldn't joke about
I love you so much
and this shows meant so much to both of
us this is the first thing we listen to
together 19 years in that basement on a
single on a twin mattress and I said one
day you will be on that show and you
will be a star and here you are and here
we are and it's like why not make it
official now you know and will you honey
will you accept oh my god are you
kidding me right now
oh my god say this is the worst is it
he's been working on this ring for a
long time I've been working with Beth
stern the great she's the only one that
had other than our publicist that yes I
had to tell him because I know he'd have
a heart attack no one else knows about
this your dad last night I pulled them
out of the hotel that's what I told him
up yes to tell him right after I told my
mom so by the way is this ring big
enough I didn't even know that putting
the ring on Maria's finger which the
ring is going on it is sort of round do
it - Robert - Maria Ford's right Marie
you should be crying she's got tears at
my this one are you serious really cause
what do you think of the ring oh my god
I love it oh my god it's amazing I'm
gonna be a married woman finally boo I
love you so much him [ __ ] balls and
grabber titties Wow
oh my god how beautiful oh my god
let's see the rock did I do okay you did
amazing
nice ring right that thought it was
outrageously great yeah she we I mean I
even had asked Beth big big carat size I
said Maria's very conservative I go but
I don't want to embarrass her and Beth
was are you gonna white piece of [ __ ]
hanging out of your lips on the goddamn
nervous I am correct I recognize it gets
me nothing
me nervous but obviously the accepted
you got your hot chick you with your
vitamin shark I'm in absolute [ __ ] I
just feel like when I leave she's gonna
go okay really the rings gonna come off
but no it's the 19 years it's about
[ __ ] time with you till right